madame
la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues
c'est avec une vive émotion que nous
avons appris le décès du journaliste de
l'Agence France Presse
urban soldes
après-midi lors d'un bombardement dans
l'est de l'Ukraine
ce jeune homme de 32 ans
riche et sa vie chaque jour au cœur du
conflit pour nous informer
au nom du Sénat tout entier je présente
nos condoléances
sa famille à ses proches et je veux
assurer de notre soutien l'ensemble des
journalistes et techniciens qui exercent
leur métier dans des circonstances
particulièrement difficiles pour nous
informer
c'est aussi avec émotion que nous avons
appris la taille object perpétré à la
synagogue de la grippe à Djerba en
Tunisie qui a coûté la vie à quatre
personnes ont l'un de nos compatriotes
Benjamin Haddad
là encore je suis certain que nos
pensées vont vers les familles des
victimes et leurs proches
je vous remercie
donc merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs je
souhaite à mon tour au nom du
gouvernement exprimé toute mon émotion
et ma solidarité après le décès hier en
Ukraine du journaliste Harman soldin qui
couvrait le conflit pour l'AFP mes
premières pensées vont à sa famille et à
ses proches elles vont à ses collègues
de l'Agence France Presse elles vont à
tous les journalistes
Harman soldin accomplissé son métier sa
passion sa vocation il est tombé parce
qu'il voulait faire connaître des faits
il est tombé parce qu'il croyait que le
devoir d'informer ne doit reculer devant
rien le journaliste la presse libre sont
essentielles pour nous concitoyens et
pour notre démocratie
alors ici avec vous à mon tour je veux
rendre hommage à Harman soldin et je
voudrais également exprimer toute mon
toute mon émotion après l'attentat en
Tunisie et là encore exprimer toute ma
solidarité aux proches des victimes je
vous remercie
[Musique]